we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p before we
get to that membership special results
we did a membership special on january
one called our 2020 membership special
and 206 people took advantage of it 206
people in the first couple days of the
year have signed up as new members
taking advantage of this discount the
code is still available if you want to
email me i will send you the code and
maybe we can even get it to 250 two
hundred and six people so far okay here
is a caller sort of equating the cult of
personality around Trump and Trump
supporters to that of those who were
defending R&B singer R Kelly
despite credible numerous allegations of
sexual assault weird urination stuff and
holding women essentially prisoner take
a listen to this call hi David ruffle
from Alabama I had two things to bring
to your attention I've noticed a slight
similarity in the cultus mindset of
Donald Trump's impeachment equal to that
of our Kelly's trials people denied the
P tapes and the testimonies and the
phone calls and all these things I kind
of see the same thing happen to a Donald
Trump and his cult followers also this
whole thing about the impeachment would
nullify his term and therefore he would
get to run again is pretty dumb on its
face because if that were the case then
when the Republicans had the house in
the Senate wouldn't they have simply
impeached their own candidate to keep
him in for another term which doesn't
make any sense yeah it doesn't so listen
first of all it's it's an aggressive
comparison Trump supporters to r.kelly
defenders but it's not crazy and I
appreciate you making it you're
absolutely right that if you could by
virtue of impeachment
give a president eligibility for an
entire additional term you would see it
strategically done by members of the
president's party and I think at most
you could argue that if Trump was
actually you know I can't think of any
way in which it makes sense I was going
to say if you if you convict Trump on
impeachment and he ends up not serving
out his last year that he could
conceivably be eligible to be vice
president in the future and if the
president died maybe he could serve out
the remainder of someone else's term but
even that doesn't really make sense
because you might be precluded
altogether if you're convicted on
impeachment I don't know the answer but
it's a very crazy thing to say for sure
we've got a great bonus show for you
today two ways to get access to the
bonus show become a member at join
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show